cette photo a changé la vie de chat par
ac en faisant le tour du monde
c'est devenu le symbole du combat des
iraniennes contre le port obligatoire du
hidjab la mère de 44 ans n'avait
pourtant jamais milité pour les droits
des femmes
c'est une femme veut se couvrir les
cheveux c'est son choix mais ce
gouvernement nous enlève notre dignité
en imposant le port du hidjab
ça leur donne le droit d'être violent
envers les femmes c'est la campagne dès
mercredi blanc lancé en mai 2010 qui est
si claire allienne à descendre dans la
rue
au début on invitait simplement les
femmes à porter un foulard blanc
il fallait juste porter du blanc j'étais
à l'aise de faire ça on change ma
première fois en iran des femmes
ordinaires de tous les milieux de toutes
les générations s'unissent pour que
cesse le harcèlement les réseaux sociaux
sont au coeur de la campagne qui devient
plus audacieuses
les femmes se dévoile en public ce film
sans hidjab et partagent leurs vidéos
exane a par contre mis tout notre
respect dans cette vidéo et d'autres
deviennent virale le régime des mollahs
tolère la dissidence pendant quelques
mois mais plus le mouvement prend de
l'ampleur plus l'étau de la répression
se resserre son patron
chappard axe avec eux la brutalité
policière était commune en iran mais la
subir en prison et un choc dès qu'il est
fils tu me lis tu insultes parce que je
suis une femme
il croit pouvoir dire ce qu'ils veulent
à une femme elle demeure hantée par le
premier enquêteurs qui l'ont interrogé
pendant cinq heures
mais le gars m'a menacée il m'a dit tu
ne reverras jamais la lumière du jour
c'est fini pour toi car tu suis une
espionne et tu sera pendu à gober d'un
an
badley j'ai été sévèrement battue j'ai
eu peur ce jour-là placé en isolement
comme plusieurs autres militantes jabara
qu'entreprend une grève de la faim
elle n'a aucun contact avec l'extérieur
sa famille ne sait pas où aller pendant
une semaine puis son père avec qui il
est en froid depuis six mois parce
qu'ils s'opposent à son engagement vient
la voir en prison comporte ni date
il m'a dit qu'il était fier de moi
j'étais très ému parce que ça faisait
six mois que je ne l'avais pas vu la
militante libéré le lendemain son mari
et son fils la supplie de cesser sa
campagne
mais après quelques jours le silence les
touffes c'était comme si quelqu'un
m'étranglait il fallait que je me vide
le coeur
j'étais furieuse contre l'enquêteur
contre le système alors j'ai commencé à
raconter ce qui m'était arrivé
l'ancienne femme d'affaires accorder des
entrevues aux médias étrangers pour
dénoncer les abus qu'elle a subies et
dont elle a été témoin en prison elle
est de nouveau arrêté en mars puis en
mai 2018 avec son fils de 9 ans
[Musique]
never forget je n'ai jamais oublié cette
scène monfils hurlaient laissez nous
partir à la maison laissez nous partir
ils les supplier bègue barbade a vu sa
mère être interrogé injurier et menotté
brusquement il a crié longtemps mais
s'en souvient à peine
miku [ __ ] à raquettes à nouveau battu et
mise en isolement dans une minuscule
toilettes elles cessent de manger et de
boire
l'avocate féministe la plus connue en
iran nasrin sotoudeh réussi à la faire
libérer
jusqu'au procès je n'ai jamais vu
quelqu'un comme elle elle est à la fois
calme et furieuse elle parle au juge
avec force
je lui dois la vie trois semaines plus
tard la militante quittent téhéran
clandestinement
elles espèrent traverser en turquie à
pied mais chez par ac et le berger qui
l'accompagnent sont interpellés à deux
pas de la frontière
hawass checking je tremblais mon coeur
palpite et je pensais que j'allais
mourir pendant tout ce temps j'avais en
tête l'image de l'anc est je le voyais
rires j'étais terrorisée à l'idée de le
revoir
finalement on les laisse passer la
nouvelle réfugier son fils qu'il a
rejoint vivent en cachette en turquie
pendant deux mois avant de prendre
l'avion pour toronto
one of the best l'iranienne adore
découvrir son nouveau pays
elle prend des cours d'histoire du
canada et rêve de droit mais avant
d'entreprendre une nouvelle carrière et
s'est donné une mission faire libérer
ses amis en prison et son avocate n'a
malgré likoud et les reculs sa part
acquis convaincu que la campagne dès
mercredi blanc a transformé son pays est
ouvert une brèche dans le mur d
oppression avant la grande majorité des
iraniennes comme elle se conformer aux
lois discriminatoires sans rien dire
plus maintenant elle réplique même à la
police de la moralité en dix ans n'est
pas de vos affaires je ne veux pas
porter le hidjab
depuis quelques années ce sont les
femmes qui font la révolution en irak
women revolution